our profits from kobe jabs have helped
at least nine people become mega rich
topping the list of new vaccine
billionaires with the ceo of moderna
and his buy and tech counterpart however
activists are now calling for an end to
the monopoly
enjoyed by big pharmaceutical
corporations
between them the nine new billionaires
have a combined net wealth of 19.3
billion dollars
enough to fully vaccinate all people in
low-income countries
1.3 times the alliance also warned that
these monopolies allow pharmaceutical
corporations
total control over the supply and price
of vaccines
as covid continues to plague the planet
only two percent of the vaccines
administered globally have gone to the
world's
50 poorest states with prices on jabs
higher
in those countries too for example in
south africa
astrazeneca's shot cost twice as much as
in the eu
at just over five dollars per shot the
head of oxfam's inequality policy max
lawson believes that vaccines that were
funded
by public money should not be about
profit
we don't think there is any crime in
making a profit
but we do think there is a problem with
monopolies
and excessive profits so you have a
situation where
pharmaceutical corporations are making
huge profits
because they have a monopoly we support
the waiving of
all intellectual property on covid19
vaccines and treatment so the waving of
patents
to create open source vaccines to share
the recipes for these successful
vaccines with
every vaccine manufacturer in the world
we think it's
dangerous to restrict production
to a small group of companies these
vaccines were funded by
public money they're publicly owned they
should not be privatized and driving
billionaire profits instead of
vaccinating
the world
you